when I not met but when Michael Jackson
was in the mall the forum shopping mall
this is like 1991 geez 1990 yet 91 so he
was wearing that red remember that red
military shirt with the yeah well those
things called up here
tassels yeah those things he passed yeah
they were on top of his shoulder it was
like a uniform we had the black fedora
like that a little long kid with him
wearing the same outfit I swear to God
and they were both wearing face masks
ovid right Lenny woman he did her face
mask yeah they both had surgical masks
on and so I'm working at the forum this
is when it was only one wing right it's
not the big forum shopping mall that is
now it was just one wing and it was so
famous because it was the first like
high-end mall and in Vegas and uh so I
worked there I worked there so I'm
standing out front of the store I was a
greeter right and uh and everyone was
like and well it's just like you can
feel the rumbling right and there's this
this thing where the the the the statue
start talking and it's a show and
Michael Wanda watch him he was watching
it from the light where the lights shine
down on it so he's up in the top of the
dome everyone is looking at his glasses
because you can see his glasses looking
down at the the thing and we'll all look
it but no one's looking at the show the
word got around in the mall that he's
there and then somehow of corner one
knew that he was in the light Luis what
the show was done he came down [ __ ] in
pandemonium you know that she you see in
the videos where it's just yeah [ __ ]
chaos and they're surrounding with
security guards and they're walking it's
exactly what happened
[ __ ] and I got his autograph did you
yeah really yeah and I remember the girl
that had a poster this [ __ ] and I know
you know who you are
she had a poster it wasn't a poster she
took a poster for I worked at this store
called Afghans like a shoe store and it
was like the two-for-one poster here I
mean or whatever it like she took the
poster down cuz she want him to sign the
back of it get it so she had a pan and I
go give me something give me something
give me half like [ __ ] it's that big
give me a hurry hurry hurry and she went
and ripped the [ __ ] corner oh yes
corners so the signatures like this big
little is and she had a [ __ ] poster I
go [ __ ] did he sign remember look at
her she ripped away [ __ ] well you think
he's gonna [ __ ] tag it he's a unicorn
the way she did it she was she panicked
she paid did he sign hers yeah he
started hers and then uh and then he's
time I might as it really it's really
cool look she'll have it yeah alright
here's the thing it went to their
ex-girlfriend she's got it we're still
friends
I'll tell her to give us in the picture
just just frame but also given but it's
the cozy it's a corner piece and I had
it framed and matted and all that
there's what the dangerous album came
out it was items go craziest [ __ ] I've
never seen and he was shaking he kept
rolling to Sue's he was so scared he
might be like he's jumping on top of
everybody
what was he more famous than Michael
Jordan I mean internal he's still like
what Muhammad Ali said one time uh I
don't know oh that's that's ok nah he is
he is here's the thing little I still
[ __ ] him have you ever looked into
that though I didn't look into it let me
tell you what Michael Jackson did
alright because Michael Jordan is huge
but I'm friends with Jon Lovitz right
you donut shop and he took me on the
road when I first got to LA and took me
on the road for about a year and a half
and I used to open for him and he's he's
best friends with Miko was that the
monkey that Michael Jackson monkey yes
he's best friends with Michael Shore of
Michael Jackson's monkeys I don't see
how cars I'll do that jump Macau he
still sees them all the time Iko likes
it when I do that know Brando Miko
Brando Oh Harlan son and that was
Michael Jackson's best friend Miko and
he was on that bad tour he was on that
bad tour old was the kid uh there's Biko
right there that's him nice
the world yeah and that's Jon Lovitz his
best friend and uh Wow yeah it's like a
tan John Lowe they always have yeah
and they always have Hawaii shirts John
is a great guy amazing funny by the way
we get those white shirts there's a
specific store in Hawaii where you have
to go and get that it's the only place
he'll get those Hawaiian shirts and
Brando son that's Marlon Brando Sumiko
yeah he's probably yishun I don't know
is he full but I got some stories about
me command so tired a lot of kids there
what hey Brando lived in Tahiti for a
long time Oh got 11 children though I do
it how many different baby mama probably
I left a lot
Miko's super super cool man and uh he
told me he's the one that put the fire
out on Michaels head what yeah when
Michael you'll see footage of when
Michael's head was on fire
yeah the Pepsi commercial and you'll see
a guy I stick a coat on his head and pie
was weak how'd he get so close with
Michael Jack uses big Marlin is
Michael's idol that's why we wanted that
no yeah
like would you remember that song he did
I forget the name of that song with
Chris Tucker in it Marlon Brando was in
it Emiko was in it as well yeah that
yeah Miko put the wire out on his head
that fire was intense by the way that's
when he got addicted to the drugs
Oh was it fireworks uh no yeah it blew
up on stage right it's a serious burn
yeah it was really bad and no one knew
really how bad it was but Pepsi right
and that's what he got addicted to pay
medicine Wow but Mika was saying uh that
tour was the most you'll never see a
tour like that ever again there's like
seven it was like seven rigs it was like
he at Michael only performed on the
weekend so it's like he did seven
Wimbley stadiums sold out seven by
himself
yeah it's like a famous band opening a
forum so you consulted Rolling Stones it
was Michael Jackson I don't think I
don't think you can get that level of
stardom now you middle never ever have
national yes to me Sherman has they're
following their groove who's who is like
that though I mean who's like who can
someone man what the hell our webiste no
one no one it's it's
inside there got to be a festival or two
acts maybe you two maybe maybe you - not
now I don't know I think you two still
has it though I think they still get
that power Drake's pretty up there I
think Wibbly how many does it hold can
you pull that up
cuz that's that's uh that's a rugby
field that's where Joshua fights and
sells it out
Joshua fights are 90,000 Joshua has
almost all his fight sir wait is that
nine thousand seated or 90,000 with the
fast
eating on the field you you sell 60,000
seats don't you
there's my camera just answer the
question please don't make me angry
good that's a good special by the way
that was my first one all right man I'm
pretty sure yeah Joshua that's where
he'd fight that cells that up okay guys
he sells out Wimbley mmm
seven times no uh check the lights he's
had he's making like you know forty
million a fight he's selling that [ __ ]
out he said oh right for big fight like
let's go there I think he fought that's
amazing just show where they fought chin
it should right there against quits go
hold on Wembley Stadium Povetkin he
fought there what was it what was the
capacity stadium Klitschko he fought
there Oh - arena Manchester Arena Oh -
arena yeah we Rita's
arenas a half the size of the stadium
okay but what about Rose Rose Bulls are
100,000 Rose Bowl no the biggest is
Michigan I think that's the big house is
a hundred I think check about that
that's clear selling out non-stop I mean
that's not but it's just crazy because
you know for expenses and and you know
you you you play seven shows at wibbly
you try and knock them all out in the
same week you know I mean for to bring
your costs down
pastas through the roof of the room
you're not on this look at that cancer
yeah the ten artists who sold it out Ed
Sheeran
well he's the number one selling artists
he that sells Beyonce yeah
is that Wimbley yeah okay but we're also
forgetting seven times
let's say we're not one time in seven
time right thing right action and you
got to remember World Tour school do
that in every city yes yes an incredible
run of sold-out shows that Wembley etch
in a run of shows okay you I need to
know the news how hold up baptizing oh
yeah those guys hey those guys tell ya
she and type in how many times did Ed
Sheeran sell it when my I forgot about
Taylor Swift you guys I don't at
Sharon's the number what you know he
passed Beyonce for most successful tour
I love Ed Church HS did he really have
to go social media cuz people were mean
to him so we're sold out nice or oh okay
that's amazing
although you know you have to understand
also the these guys have the advantage
of the Internet they have the advantage
of code point you know that's another we
had to rely on traditional Michael Jack
no I mean Michael Jackson you do one
more time and I'm gonna do an RD Laing
reference yes okay alright man take it
easy
you've been you've coming down hard on
me right now yeah and you're an elite
yeah all right now
Eminem yes he played out but this is
shows or two shows yeah now you can
reach Saul Taylor Swift can reach so
many people at the clio [ __ ] the other
aspect of that is think how many how
your people can go to any country
there's so many more yeah artists out
there yeah you have so much more access
to artists and social media and content
so to my go salt out during that'll
change yeah that's that's the other
thing yeah Michael Jackson was literally
grass root roots word-of-mouth types
sellout sellout well you know who still
like that they didn't have that he
didn't have the internet to sell tickets
because I had tickets to the bag concert
and I had to go to Bon marché were
Ticketmaster outlet was inside the
customer service area yeah yeah like
mission to buy ticket but it was an
event because who else who had to tell
her that was an event yeah see you
actually had to go buy the tickets yeah
I had to go buy remember that you could
use it all you could call on the phone
and then you had to go pick up your
ticket people would stand in line all
night outside right now right now no
social media doesn't post anything Dave
Chappelle yep yep send out radio Brito
what Radio City Music Hall 7
tene times that's beautiful you know how
many announcements Sara yeah that's even
now big there's no announcements his
tours with Rogan already sold out
they're also all those stadiums or ears
are sold out beautiful already Michael
that is so beautiful you don't know if
they're gonna do them but that's amazing
well Smith pretty big rock but the rock
can't really sell out well I like the
rock we got batteries I like the rock
way better the rock wasn't all sterile
he's on every [ __ ] drug look at his
face he's more of a no matter what I
love Will Smith yeah I love you mates
the rock or Will Smith I don't know
probably what how do you know anybody
who hates the log or Will Smith okay
that's a great question I dice I love
that question anyone that hates Will
Smith or the rock and suck my dick or
pizza can go [ __ ] go [ __ ] yourself yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]